thank you so it's very common when
people do China and go you'll be not gay
is the person will come in
doesn't matter if they're straight
sometimes you make a big deal out of
being angled
and then they hold really tight here
so if you look at me my tactic is not my
spinal displacement okay
his tactic is a turning tactic so these
don't go together so I don't have a
young tactic he's trying to do a Yin
tactic it doesn't work okay and we made
that point in uh Gateway Aikido video 15
okay so you you reverse engineer uh I'm
now nage if you reverse engineer that
I'm going to do a turn then he must do a
young chapter okay
um so hence
he's pushing me
there's his spinal displacement
and I'm going to turn him and turn
myself
this is how we do it now okay
sometimes
people not understanding the Tactical
opening for an attorney movement
make a big deal over the risk technique
so he and he'll grab really hard to hold
it in place and then I don't know why
but some for some reason
this is considered what you want to do
it's some sort of joint manipulation is
some sort of Leverage uh manipulation
again that is not Aikido we we don't
look to overpower our person our our UK
or our opponent through leverage because
Leverage is nothing more than a
mechanical advantage and mechanical
advantage is relative so for example
she's gonna do it you're not yet when
you duplicate what I did
yeah we'll let her do it the first time
this one just goes here straight under
get your weight under you and you go
okay cool don't don't let her do it
okay
so I could do it on him I could get that
leverage on him like she could not okay
um
so that's not Aikido
from a physical point of view
but from an energetic point of view
remember there's three components an
energetic component is the is the
important one because it stands between
the spiritual component and the physical
component
energetically uh there's something else
that happens
that allows for most people to not
problematize what we just did there and
that is
and uh in some lineages you'll see
they'll have a good grip but then they
let him go ahead and do that technique
this right here
so I took my palm off of the technique
and this is this is because they do not
recognize the energetic aspect of King
on waza or aiki taiso
there are two or four key areas on the
body that you must just
um be able to become sensitive to in
order to do energetic work in order to
do Coq and I keep
what it really is what it always was to
Silk Road culture okay not what we say
it is today breath or some weird psyops
or good body mechanics okay and it's you
have a spot on your palm you have a spot
on the other palm and you have that what
we call the midfoot point and the other
mid foot point
for those not in the know this is where
Jesus was crucified in the myth okay and
it's referencing these alchemical parts
of our body
what I what I'm doing here is I'm never
grabbing with my grit but I am
projecting my energy at the Palm
okay so and this is where you first get
that IC adhesion going
means I'm sensitive to the relationship
between my palm and him and I can bring
awareness to it so I don't need a grip
but I bring that idea Legion in at the
pump and if he throws the strike as
we've been doing that is now on the palm
from that spot you can again generate an
agency
so we emphasize that the who can never
ever loses the Palm connection okay so
if he does that joint manipulation
technique excuse me
but now I'm tasked with never loosening
my palm
the shoulders up okay
it doesn't really work and now if I add
the yawn tactic don't take my palm off
and he tries that same thing
it's not gonna work at all okay so it
doesn't even give the illusion that due
to some sort of superior mechanical
advantage and it might want to be
something you know it's
okay
what we're doing here
is energetically
in his utilization of the young tactic
which we notice final displacement he's
given me young energy that young energy
I'm using to set and manifest my Tom's
Enfield
then at this adhesion point
I go ahead and take it from him I use
the adhesion point I start the turn now
I create the space for ad me and I now
be in space I now move into the instance
when you look at the other variant
um he's going to ad me a 10 con
there is no
young energy really going by him so
usually the UK will go like this where
they break Center
they break their own tonden field they
deflate it and then from here he would
tend con
and I just kind of sit here
from the point of view of kazushi I'm
never really in position
I just
let go of my grip if you add all the
other factors keep your palm on
penetrate and he tries that same thing
EDB tenka he gets
stuck okay
we do the other way he's pushing and
keeping his palm on and go ahead as hard
as you can good
as hard as you can go good
he goes
and you can see that it fits together
but it is not merely me getting out of
the way
it is what I'm saying there's an
adhesion here there's a Tom bed field
here a Tom denfield here such that if he
pulls he's pulling it doesn't matter to
me
as my tandem field turns his condensed
heel turns okay
same thing is
same thing
I can still move my tondenfield and
that's what we're trying to do in time
of think of is generate the tandem field
rotate the Tomlin
generate the tomden field rotate the
time then here
okay let's try it
the Ashi Tsubaki
the footwork okay so as he's pushing I
ground Vector off the back foot that's
where everything is generate the field
I'm going to turn him
let's do the tessabaki first
go back to this one
two different types of Baku here
I'll tell you that your Aikido will
improve vastly
if you adopt the view I hold which is
there's only two testsabaki and it's the
same one just in verse the inward spiral
on the outward spiral so my hands are
either doing this
or they're doing this
if you continue the
one it becomes the other one
reverse one becomes the other one
this
this is not one okay there's no you
cannot
keep the energy flow
that is the main aspect of the misogi in
the rotation of the tanden field with
this kind of stuff okay so tessabaki is
in Taino haircut I know it looks like
it's going inward but it's a Taoist
world it's actually going outward so if
I change my footwork you would see that
it is coming upward it appears to go
inward because I rotate as it's going
into a shape
is the hour spiral you you should think
Pokeball
um now for the Ashi sabaki the footwork
midfoot Vector on the back foot so
there's that sacred spot on the right
foot in this case I turn him
I create the yin the tsuki for me to
enter into it okay
my footwork
is not going to be here
because the fight
is rotating
if I step straight
you're going to say that you lose the
outward spiral you're gonna have to make
it an Inward and up one now and when you
do that you're gonna lose eye adhesion
because you're going to go positive on
the young side plus song and you end up
pulling them around
so as the five rotates I step on the
rotation
you try to watch my right foot
as it rotates
I step on the rotation
I don't want to think in an XY grid
which is what you have here
this thing is rotating
the whole thing is rotating
so rotate your EDB EDM doesn't mean
straight it means to enter in with the
body enter into what into the center of
the rotation but the rotation is moving
so you have to also be rotating As you
move to the center of the rotation
we'll go back to the right foot
that rotation now marks
where your 10 bond is
maybe come to this side
you don't want to ten con
in such a way that that foot is now
turning out against you
and you're in this
goofy stance
this is not Marshall you're on a tight
rope and this is not anatomically sound
it's gonna hurt your knee
so as I go I enter on the rotation
and that marks
where my other foot can go
so that I don't keep over rotating it
no
straight
or in
now for weight distribution
your center of gravity
has to be go on that foot so as I intro
on that foot
my center of gravity is on that foot
which means that becomes my new ground
vector
I don't want my line of gravity between
my feet rotating between me
boom I'm on that foot
so that my 10 column is straight back
not on a curve
the turn already happened it turned
already happened here ten Commons
straight back
not over here
you're gonna do that
this turn already happened the turn
already happens in the blind spots
turned already happened
okay let's try it so we had a question
here as you can uh not feeling the
connection
um your job as UK is to maintain the
connection okay because energetically
that's what's happening okay
um you can always just engage a
connection as we demonstrated in the
final part it was a part five of uh
Gateway Aikido video 15 okay
um marshally that would open you up back
to Young tactics but energetically it's
like letting all the air out of a
balloon it just deflates okay
uh usually when we do this and you were
doing it here is as he go you you pushed
it originally and then as he goes you're
moving around in this way okay you end
up running around him
you can go a little quicker so I can
demonstrate
see that but if you pay attention you'll
be able to feel it you guys might not
see it is the pressure at the Ikea
adhesion at the contact Point goes up
and down up and down in energetic value
okay so you'll recognize it here and uh
as as you start and you feel see how I
do that you see that and now it's off
okay now for you if you watch my Center
my Center is going to disengage okay so
as he goes you see it goes backwards if
you watch but if I if I'm driving the
young energy my Center is going to go
forward and it'll fall into the empty
space
I will not walk around and keep my
balance okay
so I'm going to generate the young
energy he's grounding it there are
fields and he moves and boom you'll fall
into that empty space
I don't want you to cosmetically do the
footwork
but let us say at least cosmetically go
it's not keep going it's not this
it's not this
in my experience what it tends to be
is uh an initial fall
Ed by another skip
so let's see if it has sometimes it's
different but most times it's not
[Music]
I'll do the other one
I'm in total control
that's not India's role UK's role is to
fall into the void fall into the void
push boom fall into the void
it's terrifying to fall into the void
even in this simple title hanko drill
but it's a place where we can practice
it
Come Out Alive come out uninjured do you
see and get used to it
and it's where you can really cultivate
your releasing so I'm going to push
and fall into the void
different okay